the last year's lack of freedom seems to
have had some
unexpected effects groups promoting
naturism or wearing no clothes have
reported a huge increase in numbers
in the past 12 months the british
naturism group said at least
a thousand people had joined up during
the pandemic an increase
of around 12 percent let's get more on
this and talk to the organization's
president
mark bass good to see you fully closed
this afternoon are you
surprised uh by that the the uptake in
the past year
uh i don't think we were that surprised
so so numbers have been growing
uh slowly for the for the last couple of
years but of course
the the sort of adventure of covert and
lockdown has meant that people have been
able to spend an awful lot time
more time at home and working from home
so it was kind of inevitable that people
were going to sort of
make a few changes and and how they live
their lives and therefore
start to explore just not getting
dressed in the morning
well i suppose that's easier isn't it a
lot of people have been working at home
so they don't actually have to go out
and see people so it perhaps easier
absolutely uh if you're work if you're
working at home you can work in a way
that you find comfortable
what are people able to do then if they
are at home
uh by shedding their clothes involving
various activities
games yes so uh
what we've seen is it's a a lot of
people simply just not getting dressed
and so
whether they might be be working rather
than putting on their office suit and
tie there
they might just stay either in their
pajamas or or in nothing at all
of course being around our houses so not
so much at the moment while it's it's
cold
but uh during the warmer months people
have taken the opportunity to get out in
their gardens and
just sit in their gardens and sunbathe
um in the nude
but really what we've um been doing is
actually finding ways to provide
opportunities for
people just to connect and engage with
people so we
immediately as uh lockdown um
came into place in march last year we
immediately started running online
events so that people could do different
things
and just connect with with each other
because there was always going to be a
case that
people were going to feel very very
isolated once we were all locked in our
own homes so
and that's very that's very important
isn't it it has done
something perhaps for people's uh mental
well-being
very much so uh so we do we do quite a
lot of
um exercise activities but we also do
community activities
and this can just be um coffee mornings
and giving people a chance to get
together
i think a particularly good example
would be on christmas day this year
where of course a lot of particularly
grandparents couldn't go and see their
children and see their grandchildren
they were suddenly going to be isolated
so we said okay we're going to run
a coffee session through the afternoon
and so all these people that would have
been alone
on christmas day could just come have a
chat
drink a coffee and just find some
companionship
and as we lock down restrictions are
starting to be eased people can go out
now are there more places that
people can express themselves if you
like
uh so so we of course are busy trying to
um open up opportunities and and put on
events
so people can get out and actually um
practice naturism
outside their homes there are a number
of clubs around the countries
but i think particularly the um the
events that will take
take advantage of all the the normal
facilities that we would use for
anything else
are certainly unavailable and of course
you've also got entirely free range
things such as
uh walking and hiking which has become
incredibly popular
whilst um normal venues have been closed
just uh quickly how important is it for
people to be able
to express themselves in this way i
think it's really
important and this is not an issue
that's specific to naturism is it
we should all have the freedom to live
our lives as we see fit
with the proviso that is not doing harm
to others so
we would we would like to see um
naturists be
better recognized and better uh accepted
because really it's just
good people finding a way to relax and
have fun
and hopefully have a positive effect on
the community